hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
here chemistry phd skin care nerd and sunscreen
nerd being the sunscreen nerd person i get a lot
of questions about unusual sunscreen products and
whether or not their claims work out last time i
talked about the colorescience powder sunscreen
and the skinnies pea-sized amount claim i'll link
that in the description this time i'm back with
two more products that lots and lots of people
have asked me about evy has a range of high-tech
foam sunscreens that are meant to last for really
long on your skin so six to eight hour claims
in water with towel rubbing dermablend have
the flawless creator pigment drops that you're
meant to be able to mix into sunscreens
without compromising the spf protection
like i mentioned last time i try to talk to
the company to work out what their reasoning
is behind the claim why exactly are they
making the claim what evidence they have
and then i try to match that with what we know
about sunscreen i try to keep an open mind about
innovations even if they sound pretty unusual
because as we all know sunscreen is not that
great a lot of the time there are lots of
issues and that's why a lot of people don't
apply enough or they don't apply it properly
or they might not even wear sunscreen at all
and there are also a lot of innovations that
just don't show up in the peer-revywed literature
so a lot of the time there's just
no incentive for a company to
conduct the research and get it to a point where
it'll be accepted in the peer-revywed literature
sometimes it's just too new to be there sometimes
they just want to protect their intellectual
property and sometimes there are complicated
legal reasons why we don't have them there so i
think it's really important to talk to the company
and try to understand where they're coming from
again a disclaimer these are my opinions i could
be wrong if you disagree then let me know in the
comments please don't sue me please if you like
nerding out about the science behind skincare
products click the like the subscribe and the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
let's start with evy evy are a swedish
sunscreen brand and they have a range of these
mousse sunscreen products they're really popular
in sweden and in europe and their most impressive
claim is that their sunscreen lasts through a
lot so it lasts through six to eight hours on
your skin it lasts through dipping into water it
lasts through sweat towel rubbing and so on their
claims have actually been on my radar for a while
because they're really amazing claims they really
solve some issues that we have with sunscreens
and it would be amazing if they were true
and based on the data i've looked at i think
it could actually be true i bet some of you
never thought i would actually say that so
most sunscreen products rely on the sorts of
formulation tricks that barrier creams use as well
so in other words they try to make the sunscreen
stay on a layer on the top of your skin and they
try to make that layer as continuous and even and
as long lasting as possible some of these creams
also sink a little bit into the top layers of skin
but the problem with the product that's mostly
on the top layer is that it's on the outside
and so it shifts around it gets rubbed off and
over time that protection decreases and that's
why you're meant to reapply your sunscreen every
two hours so to try to deal with these issues some
sunscreens use different technologies to get those
sunscreen ingredients a little bit deeper into the
skin into the stratum corneum the top dead layers
you might have heard of liposomal sunscreens these
have little liposomes in them they're sort
of like little micelles and so these package
the sunscreen ingredients until it goes into
your stratum corneum and then it releases them
so you end up with a layer that's in the top layer
of your skin so it doesn't get rubbed off as much
and it's not deep enough that it'll still be near
the surface it'll still be an effective screen
evy uses a special patent that involves a mix of
glycerin dimethicone and fatty acids like lauric
acid and stearic acid this patent is actually
used for other things as well so it's used in
some treatments for atopic dermatitis or eczema
and one really interesting thing about this patent
is that it can actually increase your skin's
resistance it increases the barrier function
so it works as a better barrier and
this is very unusual for a penetration
enhancer because a lot of the time penetration
enhancers that get things deeper into your skin
will actually decrease your barrier function so it
opens it up a bit so that things can get through
this is slightly different it seems
to deliver it and then seal it in
another bonus because this isn't a barrier is that
it also doesn't seem to interfere with sweating
and it doesn't make you feel as hot the biggest
bonus with sunscreen of course is that because
it's a little bit deeper it doesn't get wiped away
or washed away anywhere near as easily so there's
a mechanism for why evy sunscreens might work
better than other sunscreens but does it actually
hold out in practice evy is sold in sweden and the
eu and they tend to have higher requirements for
claims compared to other countries they're also
a pretty famous brand in sweden they've won lots
of awards so it's not really like they'd
slip under the radar of their regulators
so i asked evy if i could see their tests and
they were nice enough to show me and they said i
could share some of the results here i don't think
they showed me all of their tests because i think
there's some intellectual property stuff they want
to keep some stuff private but yeah i'm really
impressed by the tests i've seen so far and i get
the feeling that they've done a lot more tests on
their products than a standard company would with
the tests i saw they sent their sunscreens to a
third-party testing lab and this lab used modified
versions of the official iso tests for spf and
for water resistance i talked about the iso spf
test in my video on purito basically they put the
sunscreen at two milligrams per square centimeter
on the backs of volunteers and then they expose
them to uv and see how much uv it takes for
them to get sunburned so these are the tests
they performed on the longevity claims firstly
the claim that it lasts for eight hours on skin
this was done on two of their sunscreens they took
the sunscreens put it on the volunteers and then
tested the spf and then they waited eight hours
and then tested the spf again and with both of
these the spf actually increased after eight hours
now i'm not sure if the spf actually increased
because the sunscreen interacted with the skin
differently or if it's just experimental error but
i think either way it's a pretty good indication
that the spf stays at least around the same
they also performed an 8 hour water resistance
test on their spf 50 mousse now the standard
water resistance test is only 80 minutes so
this is 480 minutes which is six times normal
they put the sunscreen on the volunteers they
sat in a whirlpool for a total of eight hours
so the actual protocol is they go in and then
they come out and they go in and they come out
and then um in total though in the
whirlpool they were there for eight hours
which is a lot then after the eight hours of
dipping probably more like 12 14 hours in total
they let the sunscreen area air dry and
then they tested the spf again the spf went
from 53 down to 35.2 which is not a massive
drop it's really impressive for eight hours
they also did towel abrasion tests on two of
their sunscreens so they applied the sunscreen
they waited 20 minutes and then they took a towel
and applied moderate pressure and stroked over it
several times then they tested the spf again and
for both of the sunscreens the spfs stayed around
the same they also tested sweat resistance
so volunteers had to sit inside a sauna at
37ish degrees for at least an hour of sweating so
they started the timer when the volunteer started
sweating profusely so there were like drips going
over the sunscreen and then after that they tested
the spf and for both of the sunscreens tested
the spf went down a little bit about 10 percent
they also did the standard 80 minutes of
water resistance with different types of
water so they did chlorinated
water and they did salt water
and in both of these circumstances
the spf went down about 10%
i am really impressed they have done quite a lot
of in vivo clinical testing on actual
humans with their actual sunscreens
this is pretty rare when it comes to sunscreens
because these tests are really expensive
i am really impressed if you look at my old video
you can see some examples where people try to use
less expensive tests and just join the dots rather
than actually test it in real life on real people
one issue with these supplementary extracurricular
tests is that they were only done on two or three
people unlike the standard spf test
which is generally done on 10 people
so these are going to be less reliable
results than the standard 10 people test
but if you look at the individual results they're
actually quite in close agreement so i think it's
reasonably reliable i would obviously prefer more
subjects and maybe tests from different labs i
think evy are actually working on getting
tests from different labs for their claims
but i also understand that these tests are
really expensive and it can be really hard
to get volunteers like if you look at
the protocols they are pretty nasty like
i would probably not want to get sunburned
and then go in and out of a hot tub for 12
14 hours and then get sunburned again
that just sounds like medieval torture
and this is considered enough by the
regulators to substantiate their claims so
there's not really a big incentive
to pay so much more for tests that
tell you pretty much the same thing so
i think these claims are pretty legit
but i also understand the regulatory perspective
where the regulators in some countries just don't
want to let a brand claim that their product lasts
for six hours even though we have these results
these tests were done on a small area of skin with
perfect application but in real life people don't
apply enough they don't apply sunscreen in certain
areas they skip bits like between your eyes around
your eyes sometimes the top of an ear having a
second application means you can fix that mistake
and so instead of having a bare patch for six
hours you would have a bare patch for two hours
i personally use the evy sunscreen and i trust
the six hour claim but i still personally try
to reapply every two hours because i know that my
application a lot of the time isn't that great but
i appreciate the fact that this sunscreen is a lot
more resistant to whatever i happen to be doing
and it's like an extra level of backup
in case i forget to reapply on time
the other product i'm talking about today
is the dermablend flawless creator drops
dermablend is a l'oreal brand and they're famous
for their high coverage products so they can cover
up tattoos they can cover up different types of
pigmentation flawless creator drops are pigmented
drops that you can use as a really lightweight
foundation or you can mix them into other products
and supposedly you can mix them into your
sunscreen without compromising the protection
it's been mentioned in sponsored content
so i assume it comes from the brand
it was mentioned on their website i think it's
currently not mentioned on their website but
in their product descriptions on ulta and on
macy's it's still there usually those product
descriptions are supplied by the brand it's
also on their instagram highlights reel it's on
some of their posts on their page they said
it in their responses from customer service
and this would be amazing if it were
true because white cast in sunscreens
is a big problem if you're in the us and you're
sensitive to avobenzone then you're kind of stuck
with mineral sunscreens and mineral sunscreens
have a white cast so if you have darker skin
and you put on a standard mineral sunscreen your
face goes white and ghostly looking and it's not
very nice tinted sunscreens usually only come in
like three colors and if you're not one of those
three colors then you're going to look a little
bit weird if you apply the right amount so this
way you can mix in one of these many shades of
pigment and get your own custom tinted sunscreen
but the issue of course is whether or not it
actually works because mixing anything into
a sunscreen could potentially disrupt its ability
to form a continuous film and it's that continuous
film that will be protecting you you don't want
random gaps and cracks in your sun protection
there's a study from july 2020 in the journal of
drugs in dermatology from dermablend that some
people have sent me and they said that this is
the study that some people are citing for proof
that the spf isn't compromised and i've looked
at this i actually looked at it for my blue light
video which i will link below and it actually
doesn't have anything to do with mixing and it
doesn't have anything to do with spf so no this
study does not show that we can do it this way
so i reached out to dermablend actually i
reached out about seven times since october
they said they'd send me the data a few times
and then eventually after a lot of back and forth
mostly forth from me and a little bit of back
from them i ended up with this response in my dms
we at dermablend recommend following the
current fda guidelines for sunscreen application
and directions for use on the sunscreen
you are applying we continually research
to innovate and improve our products in order
to share emerging learnings with dermatologists
so this is obviously a very carefully
constructed and formal statement
and i'm not sure what happened
between them promoting it
to be used in this way and this statement
i'm guessing it's one of two things
they have studies that they believe show that
mixing is fine but they want to play it safe
and not piss off the fda so they are tapping the
sign or they've realized that they don't have
enough evidence to recommend it after all and
so they're walking it back either way it seems
like the official stance from dermablend is not
to mix the pigment drops into your sunscreen so
don't mix the pigment drops into your sunscreen
but it seems like they haven't really put a lot
of effort into telling people about this change
in their policy i think they've deleted some of
their instagram posts because since october i
remember commenting on some of their posts like i
just waited for them to post about the dermablend
drop so that i could drop in a relevant comment
asking them politely for their data and i can't
actually find my comments anymore so i think they
must have deleted some of the posts but it's still
on the descriptions for flawless creator on the
ulta macy's websites they have a tutorial in
their instagram story highlight showing you how
to mix it into sunscreen they have a quote from
an interview with a dermatologist talking about
how great it is to mix these drops into sunscreen
and they even have an instagram tutorial with
hyram talking about showing you how to mix it
into your sunscreen i want to make it clear that
i'm not blaming hyram for anything because like
i said a lot of the content from the brand has
this tip and so i'm pretty sure the brand told
him he could do this and why would you not trust a
brand that's recommended by so many dermatologists
so i think dermablend could probably just put a
bit more effort into communicating
this change in their advice because
what's in my dms is very different from what you
would get if you just look through the internet
so if i were producing a product like this
this is how i would test the claim i'd get
a bunch of consumers to mix the pigment
drops into the sunscreens themselves
to see how much they mix and how they mix it
like how thoroughly then i would replicate
the worst case scenarios in the lab with a
bunch of different sunscreen formulations
and then test them on people and see what
the spf is see if the spf drops if the spf
stays around the same for all the common sunscreen
formulations then i would be happy with that claim
if it doesn't because there are a lot of different
sunscreen formulas there are lots of different
technologies used in different sunscreens
so yeah i'd like to see that done on a range
of sunscreens and have it stay good so i don't
know if that's possible i'm guessing the drops
would have to have some spf protection in them
for that to work and yeah there's just so many
different formulations with sunscreens that
i think it would be really difficult to make
sure it didn't destabilize any of them i'm
not sure if it's possible but maybe it is
that's it for today remember these are
just my opinions on the claims from these
companies with the information i have maybe
there's some information i don't have that
would be relevant as well let me know if you
agree or disagree in the comments also let
me know if you have other spf products with
weird claims that you want me to go through
i hope you liked this video if you did give
it a thumbs up you can subscribe to my channel
as well check me out on instagram and check
out my blog and i will see you next time